my name is Hana McCleary and I was the
production designer on black panther god
explorers have searched for three
centuries the golden city it's a
technological marvel well I started at
the bottom if you will and sort of
really work my way up because I wanted
to know everything after I was a set
decorator for a while about three years
a director said to me oh you should
design and I thought well maybe I should
try to do that burn it off [ __ ] knowing
Ryan changed who I was as a designer and
as a human being I mean he just and I
say that to him all the time and he's
he's such a humble man that he no no it
wasn't me but it really was him I ran
into Ryan in LA and I told him what was
going on and everything he said hey you
know I have this movie that I'm doing my
agent called me in I was like okay
what's this about hit she's like Black
Panther and then I just went to work and
I put books together and I had big giant
you know 4x8 boards and the book of just
my work and then a book of what I
thought the world of Wakanda would look
like tell me something
what do you know about what kinda my
process for almost every film that I
work on is always first about the place
so I knew that I wanted really digging
into afro futures and cuz I knew it was
gonna be a big important part of the
people that populated the country and
also to highlight Africa in a way that
we haven't ever seen before yeah kind of
starts out with a timeline what was
happening in the world and what was
happening technologically in Wakanda I
had to have a reason for every move
every building every Street everything
had a story behind it there isn't one
thing that you'll see in that movie that
does not have a story my son time we
went to Africa for about three and a
half weeks we were at this place in
South Africa called A or B Gorge it was
this like a horizontal sort of layering
of the rocks and Bacchus rendering was
tons of fun and I knew I wanted it to be
a feel of little threatening we wanted
to make the set small so he appeared
very big if you look very closely you'll
see that the wood is burnt all of the
vegetation sucked in that element of
vibranium so when you put fire to that
wood it has the same strength as
vibranium
shuri's lag was my favorite because it
was the most technological and I was
banned and determined not for everything
to be hologram so he made these sand
tables so when they drop away it leaves
the form you get to decide what kind of
kings you are going to be
[Music]
seeing the trailer at IMAX it really was
a whole different trailer to me the
detail like the colors that pops all of
the little things because there's so
many little things it blew me away in a
way that I had never experienced before
people are gonna be blown away
don't please never freeze
[Music]